mauritanie et la libération des
prisonniers du polisario le reportage de
l'équipe d'antenne 2 qui a obtenu cette
libération venezuela la veille de la
nouvelle réunion de l'opep
un pays transformé par le pétrole
bonsoir ce week-end va être marquée par
un anniversaire le 30e anniversaire de
la déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme adoptée par l'assemblée générale
des nations unies le 10 décembre 1948
exactement dans pratiquement toutes nos
éditions nous allons vous parler de ce
problème des droits de l'homme
l'actualité est remplie de centaines que
dis-je de milliers d'exemples de
violation de ses droits fondamentaux
et puis vous savez que le 18 décembre
prochain la rédaction d'antenne 2 vous
présentera une émission exceptionnelle
consacrée à la paix la paix mission
impossible ce sera d'ailleurs le thème
de cette soirée
bien évidemment on y reparlera des
droits de l'homme avec des reportages
des enquêtes effectuées un peu partout
dans le monde
exemple philippe gassot et son équipe de
reportage sont partis en mauritanie pour
faire le point sur l'évolution de ce
pays depuis le renversement du président
ould daddah son successeur le colonel
salek parle très souvent de paix depuis
qu'il est arrivé au pouvoir
alors nous avons voulu savoir tout
simplement en allant sur place s'ils
traduisait ses paroles par des actes
nous devons de rester modeste dans cette
affaire et vous allez le voir ce qui
s'est passé pendant ce reportage est
tout de même tout à fait extraordinaire
la mauritanie est en guerre une guerre
qui dure depuis trois ans après le coup
d'état de juillet le colonel ould salek
ne cesse d'affirmer sa volonté de paix
des contacts ont été pris avec le
polisario mais jusqu'à présent aucun
geste public concret n'a été fait en
faveur de la paix
nous sommes venus ici en mauritanie pour
essayer de parler avec le président de
la république de la paix nous y sommes
depuis quatre jours et dès notre arrivée
nous avons demandé à être reçus voulons
être reçus dans quelques instants
et nous parlerons avec le président ould
salek de ce qu'il désire faire en faveur
de la paix et nous lui poserons la
question de savoir s'il consent à faire
un geste
éloquent à libérer les prisonniers du
polissage
notamment d'avoir le président
oui nous sommes attendus par le
président monsieur le président je vais
vous poser une question qui dépasse mes
prérogatives de journalistes et je m'en
excuse à l'avance j'ai cru pouvoir
discerner dans votre entourage est avec
vous même une volonté de réconciliation
alors je vais vous poser la question
pouvez vous en accord avec le comité
faire devant nous un geste que certains
disent très proches
à l'heure actuelle c'est de dire libérer
certains prisonniers non pas dans un but
de propagande mais dans l'optique d'une
véritable volonté de paix dont nous
serions avec tous les mauritaniens les
témoins on s'est peut-être une question
que vous risquez de trouver inconvenante
mais je voulais poser oui mais je dois
vous dire que en fait je ne considère
même pas plus qu'une concerne que nous
avons des prisonniers de guerre et je
dois vous dire qu'effectivement ce geste
nous pouvons le faire à n'importe quel
moment et nous préparons même
certainement aller faire il est évident
que pour certains cela demande que nous
prenions un certain nombre de
dispositions discuter mais je pense que
nous avons
tout à fait la possibilité que c'est
bien dans notre intention de quitter
libérer ce que vous appelez les plus
jeunes et des gains nous vous demandons
là monsieur le président un geste
concret est ce que vous pourriez le
faire et le faire en notre présence et
nous aurions à ce moment là une simple
qualité de témoin je pense
qu'effectivement nous pouvons le faire
cela dépendra naturellement de la durée
de votre séjour j'ai comme est ce que je
sache dit si vous vous devez un principe
encore le faire un petit tour à
l'intérieur du pays très probablement qu
avant votre départ + 9
je vous remercie parce que j'espère que
votre campagne pour latter sera entendue
effectivement et que à travers le monde
ça puisse avoir les réactions ancien
camp tout cas nous vous souhaitons pour
lesquelles nous prions allah je réserve
depuis la promesse du président ould
salek il nous a fallu attendre six jours
pour savoir exactement ce qui allait se
passer durant ce laps de temps nous
n'avons été informés de rien nous ne
savions pas si les prisonniers allaient
être libérés et combien ils seraient 1
18h15 l'écart amène les prisonniers qui
ont été rassemblées à la prison de
nouakchott sur la route de boutilimitt
ils viennent de camps situés aux quatre
coins du pays ils paraissent en bonne
santé dans les bobos bleus qui ont été
distribués juste avant de partir pour la
plupart ils sont originaires de l'ex
sahara espagnol et par l'espagnol un
seul par le français
vous avez été arrêtés dans quelles
circonstances comment ça s'est passé
votre empressement pourquoi or ce que
s'est passé le bombardement de la gare
puisque ils forcent à nous tenir debout
l'agora ils ont ramassé beaucoup de
chance
on était parmi ceux qui sont impliqués
je voudrais vous demander si parmi les
gens qui sont derrière vaud l'ain vous
en connaissez qui se sont battus dans
les rangs du polisario je ne le prenais
pas ils sont tous des civils
tous ces gens sans discipline est
absolument sûrs de cela même si étaient
aussi les 10
et ça fait maintenant trois ans que vous
êtes en prison
il y en a qui sont deux ou trois ans il
ya des gens qui sont de puissantes et
des 77 et ils ne sont pas pareils
comment avez vous été traités au cours
de ces années d'emprisonnement
ne sont pas amateurs à très très mal
ils sont comme ça
vous savez ce que vous allez faire
maintenant vous vous avez ce que vous
allez devenir c'est pas exactement
est ce que maintenant vous sentez
véritablement libres 500 pour le moment
aller mais on ne sait pas encore lui ne
reverra pas sa mère avant longtemps elle
est paraît-il dans un camp près de
tindouf
déjà le polisario considère que d'une
prison ces sommes sont gardés maintenant
dans un territoire occupé
les mauritaniens nous montre les
blessures afin de prouver qu'il s'agit
bien de combat mais quoi qu'il en soit
pour nous qui sommes venus demander un
geste de paix nous pensons qu'il a été
fait et que d'autres pourront être fait
ailleurs 53 prisonniers donc libéré en
mauritanie pour cet anniversaire de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme c'est
un geste symbolique les droits de
l'homme encore avec le nicaragua a cette
fois un pays qui était loin d'être au
hit parade pour le respect des droits de
l'homme précisément est bien le
président carter vient de déclarer que
le président du nicaragua monsieur
somoza et les principaux représentants
de l'opposition ont entamé depuis
aujourd'hui des négociations sur
l'organisation d'un plébiscite qui
déterminera la nature du prochain
gouvernement
vous vous souvenez sans doute que les
dernières manifestations les dernières
émeutes des opposants avait été noyée
dans un bain de sang le président cette
fois promis une loi d'aministie pour les
prisonniers politiques à cuba cuba fidel
castro le chef de l'état a annoncé ce
matin la prochaine libération de 3000
détenus politiques cubains
les 400 premiers retrouveront la liberté
à l'occasion de noël et pourront même
quitter cuba
ces libérations prochaines sont le
résultat d'un accord entre le
gouvernement de la havane et des
personnalités en exil sur l'actualité il
ya aussi l'iran à la veille des grandes
manifestations religieuses
le point culminant des journées de deuil
des musulmans chiites ce soir téhéran la
capitale est une ville en deuil
tout est fermé les rues sont désertes il
y a des banderoles noires un peu partout
les soldats contrôlent les entrées dans
la cité et tout le monde pense aux
processions de demain dimanche la vie
économique est presque arrêtée on fait
la queue à la banque pour avoir un peu
d'argent la queue aux pompes pour avoir
un peu d'essence et les jeunes
s'entraînent pour les manifs de nous et
pourtant le gouvernement du général
azhari fait un maximum de concessions
avec l'espoir d'éviter les affrontements
les incidents les émeutes et ceux qui
pourraient en résulter à savoir le
renversement du régime
d'abord manifestation défi les cortèges
sont autorisés pour demain ensuite il
n'y aura pas de soldats sur le passage
des manifestants
enfin le couvre-feu est raccourci de
deux heures ce soir et demain soir
il commencera à 23 heures au lieu de 21
tout cela suffira-t-il pour éviter
demain que le sang coule l'opposition
des politiques et des religieux
obtiendra-t-elle départ pacifique du
chat l'armée restera tel dans tous les
cas fidèles à l'empereur
le régime iranien est en équilibre
instable au moins jusqu'à lundi
la france maintenant avec la fin à paris
à la porte de versailles de la semaine
de la jeunesse une semaine qui devait
permettre aux jeunes de s'informer sur
l'emploi les loisirs le sport
une semaine qui s'est terminée cette
après midi par la visite de monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing
le chef de l'état répondant à certaines
questions que se posent les jeunes face
à leur avenir a prononcé une allocution
dans laquelle il a insisté sur les
notions de liberté de vitalité et de
contribution à l'organisation de
l'europe et du monde
je demande à la jeunesse française de ne
pas avoir peur de l'euro
on cherche à les payer en lui expliquant
à la fois qu'elle doit avoir peur de
l'espagne et du portugal
parce qu'ils sont trop faibles et peur
de l'allemagne parce qu'elle est trop
forte
peur d'une assemblée lui alors que nous
disposons d'un droit de veto pour
empêcher l'extension de ses pouvoirs et
1 et que toute l'histoire moderne et
celle de l'affaiblissement relatif des
pouvoirs des assemblées face à ceux de
l'exécutif
est ce que cette peur des autres ne
recouvre pas une peur de nous mêmes
la peur de ne pas être à la hauteur de
l'enjeu
je souhaite que la france entre dans la
compétition de la route de l'europe
je souhaite que la france relève le gant
je veux appel à votre vitalité à votre
capacité tout mon pari qui est aussi ma
conviction est que la france est capable
de gagner dans la compétition pacifique
et fraternelle de l'euro vous direz vous
dirait non à une france chagrine replier
frileuses à une france qui deviendrait
la vieille fille de l'europe
le copain vous avez suivi ce discours
dans son entier un commentaire
oui dans cette ambiance de fête le
président la république a présenté aux
jeunes une certaine idée de la france et
une certaine idée et du monde on trouve
bien sûr quelques-uns des mots-clés
quelques unes des idées maîtresses et
président de la république en
particulier cette idée d'une croissance
douce que l'on trouvait déjà dans son
ouvrage il ya quelques années démocratie
française
et puis l'idée sur laquelle ils
insistent fortement mais plus récemment
de l'importance de la compétition
internationale mais disons qu'en gros
son discours était orientée autour de
trois thèmes la liberté la vitalité et
on l'a vu l'organisation de l'europe
plus généralement l'organisation du
monde la liberté il faut faire de la
france un exemple de liberté au passage
le président de la république règlent
leurs comptes aux deux adversaires de la
liberté ceux qui sont les partisans de
l'autoritarisme et ceux pour qui la
liberté dit-il est un droit à la
désorganisation disons un coup contre la
droite musclée où l'extrême droite et
un coup contre les gauchistes en
deviennent sans citer de nom sans citer
de noms d'ailleurs le président explique
ne citera pas de noms il n'a pas cité
non plus sur l'europe la vitalité le
président de la république estime que la
france doit gagner que les jeunes
doivent plus tard gagné là il rappelle
ce qu'est la politique de l'éducation
l'égalité des chances l'ouverture sur le
monde et le lien entre l'éducation et
l'activité professionnelle
ici une phrase qui sera souvent cité est
sans doute souvent politiquement
utiliser une société qui laisse ces
jeunes sans travail est une société
condamnée
un mot sur l'information est le prénom
d'un public estime que les jeunes
doivent être informés encore davantage
et qu'il doit y avoir dans chaque région
un centre d'information comme il en
existe un à l'échelon national et bien
mot sur le service militaire qui sera
maintenu tant que le monde vit dans une
situation de tension par nantes à la
jeunesse le président de la république a
tenu à employer le langage de la
jeunesse c'est à dire le langage de
l'avenir mais il est certain que les
préoccupations politiques immédiates
n'étaient pas totalement absente de ce
discours et on l'a bien vu à travers un
passage et que l'on vient d'écouter et
sur l'europe
le président la république n'est pas
descendu dans l'arène politique mais
visiblement quoique indirectement il a
répondu très nettement à l'appel de
jacques chirac il ya quelques jours
appelant au combat contre les dangers de
la supranationalité de l'asservissement
de l'inféodation de la france une
coïncidence intéressante est signalée
monsieur mitterrand cet après-midi par
l'état rennes il a bien souligné qu'il
n'était pas question pour les
socialistes d'être la roue de secours de
l'udf ni de servir la propagande du
président de la république mais il a dit
aussi que le pc et le rpr pratiquer une
politique réactionnaire de peur à propos
de l'europe
la peur c'est aussi l'argument qui était
utilisé les utiliser par le prêt dans
les républiques l'europe on le voit et
bien maintenant au coeur de la vie
politique française
et puis dans les petites phrases
politiques prononcer ce week-end il ya
également l'europe d'ailleurs jacques
blanc secrétaire général du parti
républicain a dit dans l'essonne
l'europe est un sujet trop sérieux pour
être traité à coup de slogans
pas de mélodrame pas de psychodrame le
débat doit se développer dans la carte
et raymond barre lui dans une interview
accordée à fr3 provence côte d'azur a
dit à propos de son voyage en corse
je veux m'assurer sur le terrain de
l'exécution des décisions prises à
l'occasion dû voyage du chef de l'état
en corse
je vais m'informer par moi même auprès
des responsables des problèmes
que ceux qui se posent dans l'île à
propos de la corse
il ya eu six attentats commis depuis
hier soir contre des gendarmeries en
corse provoquant une certaine tension
dans l'île à quelques heures du voyage
de raymond barre et puis on a appris
d'ailleurs que monsieur bertolini un
fonctionnaire blessé hier dans
l'explosion de sa voiture a dû être
amputé aujourd'hui maintenant la
politique pour quelques mois encore avec
la convention nationale de la fédération
des républicains de progrès il s'agit
des gaullistes de gauche
une fédération plus tôt une convention
nationale au cours de laquelle monsieur
charbonnel a rappelé qu'il était pour
une europe qui respecte tout le traité
de rome
mais rien que le traité pas
d'intégration supranationale ajoute
monsieur charbonnel il convient de
refuser pour l'europe tout régime
d'assemblée et puis il y avait à vitry
dans le val-de-marne la rencontre du
bureau politique du parti communiste et
de 400 intellectuels communistes deux
journées de travail à huit clos elles se
termineront ses journées de travail
demain soir à 19h30 les participants à
ce débat ont été répartis en quatre
groupes de 100 personnes
et apparemment il n'y aura pas de thème
particulier mais plutôt une discussion
très large
nous aurons l'occasion je pense demain
de revenir sur cette rencontre de vitry
qui se déroule en présence de georges
marchais le dossier social avec tout
d'abord l'annoncé de nouveaux
licenciements d'ici à la fin de l'année
1980 dont le groupe essilor cela qu en
lorraine 8500 emplois devraient être
supprimés
la confirmation viendra la semaine
prochaine avec la publication d'un
nouveau plan de restructuration de la
sidérurgie française fin de la grève au
centre de tri postal de bordeaux et l'as
durer 16 jours cette grève et femmes la
grève également des conducteurs du
réseau sud-est à la gare de lyon
elle durait depuis douze jours le trafic
est donc maintenant normal sur le réseau
banlieue le lait va augmenter le lait
entier + 6 centimes par litre c'est à
dire environ 3% d'augmentation cela a
été fixé hier par le comité national des
prix la grève des dockers
le mouvement déclenché pour 24 heures
par la cgt a été suivi pratiquement à
100% aujourd'hui paralysant ainsi les
opérations commerciales dans les ports
français
la justice maintenant avec le verdict de
la cour d'assises de versailles les
jurés des yvelines ont accordé les
circonstances atténuantes à mohamed
yahiaoui
il a été condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité ce verdict de la
cour d'assises des yvelines démontre le
poids l'importance de l'analyse des
psychiatres dans l'exercice de la
justice moderne
ce verdict démontre aussi le scrupule
qu'on la majorité des jurés de ne pas
engager leur responsabilité personnelle
sur de l'à peu près le scrupule de ne
pas juger n'importe quoi de n'importe
quelle façon
au premier procès à evry il ya un an
l'absence d'un certain nombre de
rapports d'examen médicaux avaient privé
les jurés de l'essonne d'éléments
considérable d'appréciation mais comme
s'y ajouter plusieurs erreurs de
procédure d'instruction la cour de
cassation avait annulé ce verdict hier à
versailles
le rapport du médecin psychiatre yves
roumajon a mis en évidence et pour la
première fois les tendances épileptique
de mohamed yahiaoui tendance dont
l'explosion a sans doute provoqué cette
vague de folie meurtrière au cours de
laquelle il a tué par deux fois qui peut
mesurer exactement le degré de
conscience d'un homme dans cet état là
personne seule
le psychiatre s'approche de ce monde
diffus qu'est la raison de l'homme
perturbé bouleversé déstructuré par des
vagues des pulsions venus du fond de
lui-même et qu'il ne contrôle pas et
c'est finalement au psychiatre de
répondre comme il croit pouvoir le faire
aux avocats aux juges et aux jurés qui
lui demande mais que pensait-il à ce
moment là plus que le procès de la peine
de mort
ces assises de versailles auront été le
procès du doute du doute sur la
véritable responsabilité d'un homme dont
je me demande d'ailleurs s'il a bien
compris ce qu'on disait autour de lui
robert hersant n'aidera pas le comité du
bateau pour le vietnam ce bateau qui
devait être affrétés pour aller le
chercher des réfugiés
s'enfuyant du sud vietnam robert hersant
a dit ce matin dans une lettre publiée
par le figaro une lettre adressée à
olivier todd rédacteur en chef de
l'hebdomadaire l'express
je ne veux pas mêler mes journaux avec
ceux qui furent les complices des
agresseurs du sud vietnam le pétrole
maintenant avec la nouvelle réunion qui
doit se tenir dans six jours de réunion
des pays producteurs de pétrole
il a encore de beaux jours le pétrole
dit l'hebdomadaire l'express cette
semaine la crise du pétrole n'aura pas
lieu n'ajoute l'express
pourtant il faut noter que le venezuela
aujourd'hui s'est déclaré partisan d'une
hausse modérée mais non infime des prix
du pétrole le venezuela c'est le
cinquième producteur mondial de pétrole
sa position est donc importante
philippe chatenet et une équipe du
journal d'antenne 2 reviennent du
venezuela
le venezuela s'est d'abord du pétrole
beaucoup de pétrole l'année dernière
presque 119 millions de tonnes ont été
produits ce qui place le venezuela au
cinquième rang mondial
cette richesse fabuleuse et concentrés
ici dans le lac de maracaibo à l'ouest
du pays sur les treize mille kilomètres
carrés du lac
il y a plus de 13000 puits reliés par
vingt mille kilomètres de pipelines sous
le pétrole rapporte chaque année plus de
8 milliards de dollars au venezuela
depuis la nationalisation décidé il ya
cinq ans non seulement le pétrole mais
aussi l'extraction le transport et le
raffinage sont entièrement vénézuélien
mais maracaibo exploiter maintenant
dupuis exactement cent entre va
s'épuiser
malgré les nouveaux forages comme celui
ci la production plafonnent c'est une
course de vitesse qui s'est engagée car
le pétrole d'aujourd'hui doit financer
le venezuela de demain joue un rôle très
important dans le développement du
venezuela
de toute façon nous cherchons un
développement plus complet pas
dépendants du pétrole
nous savons de développer d autres
sources des richesses l'industrie
métallurgique l'agriculture l'industrie
et c'est comme le montre ce cui
familièrement déguisé en zèbre le
pétrole fait partie intégrante de la vie
à maracaibo c'est le grand danger car on
s'entend on s'est habitué à vivre parmi
les derricks on s'est habitué à voir le
pétrole et les pétrodollars coulaient à
flots depuis quelques années les
vénézuéliens se sont rendu compte de la
nécessité de tirer des bénéfices
durables du pétrole ils ont même inventé
un slogan il faut semer le pétrole
la nature qui a tellement favoriser le
venezuela on lui donnant le pétrole de
maracaibo s'est montré plus capricieuse
ailleurs ici par exemple dans les llanos
les immenses plaines du sud six mois par
an les ja no sont inondés comme lorsque
nous y étions mais pendant l'autre
moitié de l'année la sécheresse est
telle qu'une partie du bétail meurt de
soif
pris dans le cycle inondations
sécheresses la production des llanos
pourtant la meilleure terre d'élevage
potentiel du pays restent faibles
l'année dernière le venezuela a dû
importer pour près de 2 milliards de
dollars de nourriture alors à coup de
pétrodollars on corrige la nature 300
millions de francs ont déjà été investis
pour construire un système gigantesque
de digues sur les premières parcelles
ainsi protéger la densité animale a pu
être multiplié par dix
le venezuela de l'an 2000 se construit
aussi à l'est dans la région de guayana
en pleine forêt vierge surgissent
barrage industrie ville nouvelle tout
est fondé sur les ressources que recèle
la jungle est d'abord l'énergie
ce barrage aguri qui sera l'un des trois
plus grands au monde fournit
l'électricité à la pièce maîtresse du
développement de la guyane à la
sidérurgie
ici aussi on a semé les pétrodollars à
tour de bras
un exemple ce paquebot de 80 mille
tonnes à remonter l'orénoque sur 350 km
pour loger 15 cents travailleurs de
l'acier
la logique est simple construire 15
cents logements auraient pris trois ans
et ici on n'a pas trois ans à perte
la sir est un symbole magique pour les
pays en voie de développement
le venezuela n'y échappe pas pour avoir
son acier
rien n'est trop beau on achète à
l'étranger les techniques les plus
modernes et les plus chères dans un an
le venezuela produira 5 millions de
tonnes dans dix ans 15 millions de
tonnes
et qu'importe la crise mondiale de
surproduction
mais il ya plus grave cette course
effrénée à l'industrialisation cette
multiplication quasi miraculeuse des
tonnes d'acier d'aluminium des kilowatts
et des bars ils coûtent cher en termes
humains caracas son et une image
frappante
derrière la façade des gratte ciels il y
à un autre caracas des bidonvilles
immense où ils sont un million le tiers
de la population à vivre trop souvent
sans eau potable sans ego sans
électricité
ces bidonvilles les ranchs et hausse en
serre caracas comme une couronne
d'épinés derrière les rêves chatoyant de
pétrole et d'acier il reste beaucoup de
misères et demain précisément dans notre
journal de 20h nous verrons le deuxième
volet de cette enquête la misère dans
les bidonvilles du venezuela la page des
sports de ce journal maintenant avec
tout d'abord l'arrivée à paris ce matin
du vainqueur de la transatlantique
française en solitaire le canadien mike
birch
il était l'invité cet après midi des
jeux du stade l'émission de robert
chapatte et de jalousie avant cela en
fin de matinée il a été reçu à la
résidence de l'ambassadeur du canada en
france par le premier ministre canadien
monsieur trudeau le passage à paris
henri bodiguel qui était sur place en a
profité pour demander à michael burke ce
qu'il pensait du retard d'alain colas le
navigateur français dont on est toujours
sans nouvelle
why you say maintenant oui je commence à
être inquiet je ne voulais pas parler
d'alain colas mais je suis moi aussi
concerné par ce qui lui arrive
pardon une course en solitaire tout peut
arriver mais dans le cas présent on peut
penser qu'il est passé par dessus bord
beaucoup de choses peuvent se produire
pendant une course mais il s'agit de
risques que l'on connaît en prenant le
départ mais surtout avant tout cette
course en solitaire c'est risquer de
passer par dessus bord en ski début des
épreuves de la coupe du monde vainqueur
en descente ce chez les dames en italie
anne-marie meilleure preuve est chez les
hommes dans le slalom géant le spadois
stenmark et gagner facilement lui en
autriche
il y avait également du tennis
aujourd'hui la coupe davis nous allons
avoir quelques images avec daniel kazan
mais je vous propose de commencer tout
de suite par le rugby le grand chelem
historique réalisé par les all blacks
qui ont battu les écossais cet après
midi 18 à 9 une victoire qui aurait pu
être remise en question à cinq minutes
de la fin même douzaine sur cette couche
et vos 16 c'est un véritable tube
soucieuse du lot somme va donner à
mcgeechan qui tente le drop mais sera
peu près les écossais n'égalise vont pas
au contraire osbourne et robertson par
copier et robertson va marquer entre les
poteaux un essai qui sera transformé
victoire des all blacks 18 h
il reste aux écossais une double
consolation pour la première fois depuis
42 ans
ils ont marqué un essai all blacks et
cet essai est le premier que les néo
zélandais
et encaissent en 10 matches
coupe davis en californie les états unis
et la grande bretagne sont à égalité
après les deux premiers simples mcenroe
a écrasé john light six amis je suis de
mes mots tram a terrassé gottfried ici
au service pour la balle de match
goodwin va perdre ce point et le match
alors qu'il a eu lui même au troisième
set une balle de match
victoire de mottram donc 4 6 2 6 10 8 6
4 6 3 le coupable de gottfried ne
devrait pas empêché les états unis de
remporter la coupe davis pour la 25e
fois il me reste à vous donner le lait
ou plutôt à vous rappeler les pronostics
pierrette brès vous a déjà présenté dans
samedi amy présenté par claude mongeau
cet après midi il y aura un tiercé donc
demain voici les préférés les petits
préférés de pierrette brès car d'azur le
13 à et 4 le 6 août chez wendel 3
reliant tu mêles 17 montcourt leucate
mirassou le 5 et vorm le set rapidement
la météo pour demain les prévisions dans
le télégramme que nous ont transmis les
spécialistes sur l'ensemble du pays
temps doux pour la saison sur les
régions méridionales assez beau temps
après la dissipation des brumes
matinales danse en aquitaine sur les
régions septentrionales temps nuageux
avec quelques pluies intermittentes
je donne rendez vous demain pour le
journal de la mi-journée à 13h15 vous
retrouverez dans la soirée avec claude
et france roche pour sa rubrique cinéma
le dernier journal étant fixé à 23h35
je souhaite une très belle soirée sur
antenne 2